what a great crowd welcome all of you
the only normal people in all of New
York are right here welcome back our
live audience show
thank you for joining us on Hannity to
begin though tonight with a Fox News
Alert breaking tonight Hunter Biden will
likely be indicted by the end of this
month I know
but there's a lot more
special counsel David Weiss is seeking
at least one gun charge against Hunter
but make no mistake let me be very clear
up front here this is not a cause for
celebration just not because you don't
want to ever see anybody arrested or
have hard times in their life but
um it's hardly even a step in the right
direction when we talk about Blind
Justice being blind Hunter is now facing
prosecution only because David Weiss got
caught giving Hunter Biden that get out
of jail free card in the form of what
was the sweetest of all sweetheart deals
in the history no jail time no serious
charges a gentle slap on the wrist full
immunity hidden deep into the plea deal
trying to get that past the judge and
remember the original plan was no
charges at all whatsoever and then the
IRS whistleblowers made that plan
Obsolete and impossible so David Weiss
came up with Plan B that included
immunity and that became the next best
option no jail time no real charges it
was all going according to plan until
that Delaware federal judge started
asking important and pivotal questions
the best question in my mind was to the
prosecutor have you ever seen a
diversion agreement talking about the
gun portion of the agreement that is so
broad that it encompasses crimes in
other cases they tried to bury the
immunity in the gun provision of the
plea deal the prosecutor had to reply
know your honor now ultimately the judge
and the defense they rejected the deal
the judge rightfully so because she
didn't see that deal until that morning
and that never had been been given out
to anybody else and the defense they
wanted to get out of jail free card with
that immunity now equally important we
have now learned from both the IRS and
FBI whistleblowers that in fact Weiss
and others purposely were slow walking
the investigation into Hunter Biden for
years and that that wives as you all
know we've reported it he let the
statute of limitations run out on very
serious tax felonies for a lot of
important years especially with barisma
money now these are felonies you know
you think anybody with the last name
Trump they would ever get this type of
treatment I don't think so they never
even interviewed Hunter Biden in a four
plus year investigation after the entire
Biden family that was tipped off about
the FBI no investigation no interview of
of Hunter no future interrogation so
here we are either David Weiss now
special counsel is the most incompetent
lawyer in the world or this was all very
intentional I happen to believe the
latter naturally mayor Garland just
promoted Weiss now he's a special
counsel the guy already had five years
to bring charges against Hunter and by
the way the evidence is overwhelming in
my viewing controvertible the guy who
seemingly helped Joe and Hunter of a
Justice he's now running the special
counsel investigation simultaneously
protecting himself and Mary Garland now
David Weiss and the Democrats of the doj
they probably believe the gun charge
will appease critics they think that
we're obsessed with just Hunter Biden
and they couldn't be more wrong yeah we
are concerned with Justice and equal
application of the law and equal justice
under the law and that applies to Hunter
Biden but the more serious investigation
is happening in the house uh oversight
committee with James Comer and the house
Judiciary and in the house ways the
means committee and that's about Joe
Biden the big guy himself we now have
what we have been unfolding every night
on this show mounting evidence against a
sitting president that directly
implicates him in what maybell well be
the biggest political scandal in the
history of this country real influence
penalty peddling bribery and money
laundering allegations and many of the
crimes Hunter has suspect instead of
committing and this particular gun
charge well this does not implicate Joe
in any way how convenient so the big guy
he remains in a bubble for now save from
any real legal scrutiny for now now mark
my words on this it will stay that way
if Biden runs for reelection and the
media mob and the Democratic Leadership
want him to run for president Because
unless the Democrats and their
propaganda allies in the media mob
decide that Joe needs to go he's not up
to the job and they prefer another
candidate if a few influential Democrats
and a few influential media mob swamp
creatures start well sounding like me in
other words when they start telling you
the truth for once on these important
issues on these on the millions of
dollars that the Biden family made with
no experience at all cashing in on on
Joe's name and Joe's position as vice
president if they start reporting all
this that will be the canary in the coal
mine and that means that they're going
to try and push Joe out in the end it'll
be Democrats that push him out not
Republicans as for now mayor Garland
David Weiss they continue to protect Joe
at all costs even if that means offering
up Hunter as a sacrificial land him so
while David Weiss well he pretends to
care about a gun charge we are focused
on the real bribery money laundering
fairer violation allegations that we now
have more and more evidence developing
every day for example let's look at
Ukraine let's go look at our timeline
October 2015. that's when the Obama
White House well they decided to give
Ukraine a billion dollars in loan
guarantees because they had made enough
progress regarding corruption in Ukraine
okay a short time later December 4th
2015 same year Hunter Biden he is
meeting with barisma Executives they are
in Dubai they were facing a corruption
probe by a prosecutor by the name of
Victor shulkin okay now in this
particular case they pleaded with Hunter
to get help they needed help from D.C
Barista Executives Hunter arranged the
call while he was in Dubai with the
Barista Executives with his DC help that
would be his VP father Joe well four or
five days later then Vice President Joe
Biden he happened to be in Ukraine and
as the Obama administration's Point
person to Ukraine that's when Joe was
supposed to deliver the billion dollars
per Obama foreign policy instead Joe
decided to leverage that one billion
dollars forced Ukraine to fire Victor
shulkin the prosecutor investigating
well Barista Holdings the gas and oil
giant that was paying his son a ton of
money he gave him six hours to fire him
son of a bee they fired the guy Ukraine
got their billion in loan guarantees
Barista stayed in business Hunter kept
getting paid for a job in which he
admitted on Good Morning America he had
no experience it and was an admitted
addict at the time now according to a
trusted FBI Source if you go back to the
1023 form that of course James Coleman's
committee had to fight for they didn't
want to hand it over willingly both
Hunter and Joe each accepted five
million dollars five million for one
Biden five million for another Biden and
by the way it'll take you over ten years
it'll take you over 10 long years to
find out where that money came from
before anybody's going to figure it out
now we do know that at least nine Biden
family members including grandchildren
receive Farm payments pass through shell
corporations identified by Congressman
James Comer though you wonder what does
the grandchildren do for all of this
money how did they earn that money
Hunter didn't have experience how did he
earn millions of dollars you know we got
you know millions of dollars China
Russia uh Ukraine Kazakhstan Romania
Mexico now according to John Solomon he
will join us in a minute as early as
2015 even the Security and Exchange
Commission was receiving alerts about
suspicious transactions and fraudulent
schemes involving the Biden's
transactions but it wasn't just Ukraine
there were payments as I said from China
Russia Kazakhstan Romania Mexico and
others at the very same time then Vice
President Joe Biden was meeting with
many of these wealth and Wealthy
foreigners and oligarchs and Hunters
foreign business partners they were
making his family rich but Joe had said
over and over again as a candidate and
the president he'd never once spoken to
Hunter or his brother or anybody for
that matter about their foreign business
dealings there were dinners at the Cafe
Milano with the former first lady of
Moscow and others numerous phone calls
according to Devin Archer and other
Communications Hunter meanwhile had a
direct line to the White House he
received government emails about Ukraine
they don't want to give them to us he
attended State dinners he set up White
House meetings with a lot of these
foreign business partners and then his
father Joe well he lied about all of
that why would y'all lie about something
as critical as that now to top it off
Hunter decided not to pay taxes on what
was millions of dollars in income I
guess it was tough for Hunter based on
his own Communications he had to give in
his words half his income to Pops he
told that to his sister in a in an email
that was captured on the laptop from
hell and yet despite all of this the
special counsel David Weiss with all of
his special powers is rounding the
corner on a relatively minor Firearms
indictment after a five plus year
investigation this is obscene this is
not Justice that is blind this is not
equal justice this is not equal
application of our laws the fix has been
in and still is in imagine if the names
were different switch the name Joe Biden
and make it Donald Trump switch the name
Hunter Biden with Don Jr or Eric or
Ivanka or Baron Trump there is no equal
justice no equal application of our laws
this is corruption through and through
and this is what the Biden protection
racket is all about Joe Biden Mary
Garland you know what this is why we
need new people hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else